on this Earth Day we're taking you to
Panama it's there that one of the first
mass relocations of people due to
climate change is set to happen more
than one thousand people of the gunayala
tribe will have to leave a group of
islands off the country's northern coast
due to sea level rise Manuel pohork has
traveled there and has this report
for hundreds of years these Waters have
acted as the buffer that protects the
gunayala culture
or Crab Island every square inch is
occupied
houses perched right on the edge of the
water
we arrived by boat at one of the
Island's tiny ports to see it for
ourselves gracias
here there are no cars or motorcycles
women dress in traditional attire
[Music]
who Gather in their government Hall
speak the native tongue
it's where we met Magdalena Martinez who
also speaks Spanish
we had to leave due to Great forces she
says recounting how the gunayala escaped
aggression from Spanish colonizers and
the Panamanian government by settling on
these islands Generations ago but now
the tide is turning
flooding like this has become more
frequent due to the effects of sea level
rise on these low-lying islands
especially during the rainy season
the evidence of which we saw firsthand
when Magdalena Martinez showed us around
the Island's fragile coastline
so that's the watermark
you could see how high the water had
come into one of their schools
and into some homes during high tide
yeah you're not making the sauce
the sad reality to be sure
overpopulation of the islands is a
problem but scientists say the bigger
threat is climate change by 2050 they'll
be underwater underwater that's less
than 30 years less than 30 years we
spoke with Laurel Avila of Panama's
Ministry of the environment in the
country's capital it's a real thing it's
a real problem it's a real problem she
says sea level rise is caused by carbon
emissions raising the Earth's
temperature causing glaciers to melt and
water molecules to expand
the water around the islands Rose at a
rate of about one millimeter a year in
the 1960s now it's about 3.5 millimeters
a year meaning the gunayala will have to
leave they have to be moved they have to
there's no other option there's no other
option the rise of the sea level is not
going to stop
it's something people here have slowly
started to accept after years of putting
up a fight they've used rocks and
remnants of coral reef to try to reclaim
or expand their land entonces
all the time
it keeps going up
Augusta Boyd says it's been the only way
to keep the water at Bay the owner of
one of the few stores on the island
realizes it's a losing battle and
they'll have to leave it all behind it's
very difficult
everything you did here
foreign this will be their new home a
stark cookie cutter subdivision rows of
houses that could not be more different
than life on guardi sugdube
it's being built on land owned by the
gunayala with the majority of the
funding from the Panamanian government
about 13 million dollars so far but
already facing delays how far are we
from the island
kilometers two kilometers away from the
island
Alexander Jaime is with Panama's
Ministry of housing this place is so
different from what they're used to
there's no other option
um
there's no other place to go
other than here no I'm so lucky so lucky
back at guardi suit
is the basket a group of women including
Magdalena Martinez was eager to show me
these homemade baskets they use for
groceries you don't want plastic bags at
the store you want to bring your
s
this is to protect the environment
this is your home my home your home
they view climate change as a problem
caused by the industrialized World
unfairly bearing down on them and the
culture they've so fiercely defended the
sign there says people who lose their
tradition lose their soul
are you concerned about losing the
tradition
no
we don't have that fear she says because
we carry the tradition inside
yet that determination doesn't
completely mask the fear of facing this
new threat to their culture
for CBS Saturday morning Manuel
bajorquez guardi suktube Panama
that's got to be hard to move from a
water-based communal lifestyle to one
that's strictly land-based I I don't
know how do you make that that
transition and this is happening so fast
I mean in less than 30 years all of that
will be underwater and they say they
will retain their culture but it's so
difficult to see how some of those
Traditions stay alive and so different
how it looks where they are now versus
yes this new housing that's coming in
looks natural